crisis económica pobreza y desempleo es
lo que enfrentan miles de argentinos que
se volcaron a las calles para exigirle
un cambio en sus políticas al presidente
Alberto Fernández vamos a estar haciendo
una permanencia en Plaza de Mayo ya que
estamos en una situación cada vez más
grave con el 50% de la población por
debajo de la línea de pobreza aumentan
cada vez más los porcentaje de
indigencia una inflación en los
productos alimentarios del 8% y porque
acaban de cambiar
a la ministra de economía y no ha
cambiado nada
los manifestantes buscan que el gobierno
apruebe una renta básica universal y un
Bono especial para jubilados y
trabajadores no registrados además
rechazan las medidas de austeridad que
anunció la nueva ministra de economía
Silvina bataques con las que buscan
cumplir los pagos al fondo monetario
internacional a quien le deben unos 44
mil millones de dólares los
manifestantes quieren que el dinero que
ganancia la deuda externa se destine a
los más pobres de Argentina parece que
el pueblo
estamos esta receta del fondo que no
podemos seguir diciendo la merceda que
no podemos ir a la góndola y no poder
comprar y encima cuando vamos a poder
comprar no hay abastecimiento de
productos como pasa con el aceite con la
harina muchas veces con el azúcar la
inflación podría acercarse al 80% este
año según analistas además conforme los
últimos datos oficiales la pobreza
afecta al 37,3% de los argentinos